this is another one of the 10 short
videos these
are all about questions having to do
with philosophy and philosophers
some of them have to do with individual
philosophers some of them have to do
with the practice of philosophy
in a kind of academic way and some of
them have to do with particular topics
or issues or movements i've been
soliciting questions ever since i ran
out of vu footage
on the the video that i use for
people to put them as comments actually
questions and comments
and um i've got plenty on philosophy now
so that's why i'm shooting this one i'm
still putting together some on religion
and some
on education so if you have questions in
those areas go ahead and send them in
i'm also
you know willing to do stuff about
politics about what i think about
contemporary events
about you know personal things having to
do with my
my background or experiences and as i
get 10
i put them together like i like i have
with this one so i've got philosophy one
so that's what you're getting
here in this this particular video
10 shorts specifically about
philosophical thinkers
issues movements and the practice of
philosophy
so this is a good question by jf essa or
asa
and it's a very general one
what advice do you give for someone who
wants to be a scholar
of a great thinker or i'm guessing you
know somebody who focuses specifically
on a great thinker like a plato scholar
or a nietzsche scholar
or a mcintyre scholar so
what advice would i give i guess it
would fall into a couple different
categories
one is i think some people
when they're when they're studying
um they they fall into a kind of trap
where they figure i've put this much
work and time into this
this guy so i have to become a scholar
on this this person i have to
you know keep continuing it even if they
don't really enjoy
reading that person or they they find
that you know the enthusiasm that they
had for their ideas and their works at
the beginning
tends to run out and i think that it's
important to to
recognize that there's a lot of people
that you could study in philosophy
and not all of them are going to be
equally interesting or
appealing so it's important to sort of
follow your passion
with with that sort of thing because
that'll carry you through
more practical advice you if you want to
be a plato scholar you
you want to read everything that plato
has written and you want to read it
multiple times and keep reading it over
and over again
and you know sort of seeing how the
texts connect up with each other
and the same would go you know for
nietzsche for heidegger for anybody that
you pick
you probably also want to read some of
the better secondary literature out
there to see what other people make
of these people but you don't want to be
um just you know circling in these these
spirals around the secondary literature
you want to spend your time
on that that particular thinker
and i guess the other thing that i would
say is you know
you want to keep on growing
as as a scholar you know whether that's
in terms of writing
in terms of research in terms of
teaching in terms of presentations to
other people
brandon wadlington asks i was wondering
if you could talk about what interests
you about thomas hobbs philosophy
i remember you mentioning him as someone
that you really liked
and i suppose you could say that i
really do like hobbes in a certain sense
but i also see hobbs as
representing a kind of way of
thinking about things or maybe an end
point of
thinking that is particularly dangerous
and so i like hobbs as a philosopher
despite the fact that he's awfully
terribly reductionist and polemical
about things
and i think he is you know a first-rate
philosopher in many respects he's of the
first order of importance
but he also shows us particularly in
leviathan
where a certain way of thinking about
political power its relationship with
religion
with public discourse with argument
with um philosophy as it used to be
practiced
actually ends up you know with this
the sovereign who not only has to have a
monopoly on force but it actually has to
dominate the intellectual sphere and
cannot
tolerate any sort of any sort of
opposition
to to its own way of viewing things
so all previous philosophy has to be
sort of banished
and and hobbes is is one of the most
stark representatives of this
this view and i see hobbs as
sort of the philosopher of
of the 20th century in in a lot of
respects
by you know thinking about how how some
discourses just kind of
crowd out other discourses and say you
can't belong here
not only you can't say what you're going
to say here you can't even be here
because you think the wrong way
i see hobbs as kind of a a uh theorist
of that so i see him more as a danger
and it's instrumental to look it's very
good to look at you know
the dangers involved then as the kind of
philosophy i want to endorse
this is a question from paul james
kimberly and he asked what is your
opinion on heidegger's nazism how does
it relate to our understanding of his
philosophy
and this is a question that's been much
debated for for several decades now
in the continental philosophy community
for some people just having an
affiliation like that's enough to write
you know right person off altogether
which i think is really a stupid way of
doing philosophy
um you know there's a lot if you start
picking
uh particularly from from the vantage
point of the the victorious present
and then looking at unsavory connections
that people have you can eliminate an
awful lot of the history of philosophy
the question that people have to ask
is is the the fact that heidegger became
a member of the nazi party gave this
rector's address
you know use some of the language of of
you know
the nazis being the voice of being for a
certain amount of time
in his his work is that something that's
really
central to the contributions that he
made in philosophy
and i think that the answer unless
you're really looking at things in a
tendentious way
is no um i think that a lot of the great
contributions that he made and i think
heidegger actually did make a lot of
important contributions to philosophy
have nothing to do with with any of that
um
heidegger also said some some dumb
things that had nothing to do with
nazism you know his his view on values
is always being something that we're
kind of
uh uh putting on to being rather than
allowing being to speak
i think is is misguided i think that his
his uh
view that german and greek are really
classical greek are really the only
philosophical languages that latin
and french and english can't count as
such i think that's that's
you know sort of uh
german silliness on on his part uh and i
think that you know
we have to be very careful about
distinguishing what's what's
central in somebody's philosophy from
some of their more peripheral
engagements and commitments and and not
take that as
what's really essential that requires
actually spending time
reading studying thinking about
heidegger's works and that that's a
difficult thing that a lot of people
want to stay away from i think
so mr poig123 asks
talk a little bit about schopenhauer it
would be cool to hear your views on
on him and schopenhauer is one of those
people who
i don't spend an awful lot of time on
either in reading or in teaching or
writing
i recognize his importance within a
certain
you know tradition of german idealism
and i
i particularly am attracted to his
notion that things are not so rational
and as uh easy to figure
as um people you know
people in that tradition like like kant
and ficta
and hegel had had made things out to be
um and he is important for understanding
nietzsche but i would say that
schopenhauer is kind of a
a you know second tier philosopher
um and you know
i suppose if i spend more time on him i
would find out
that you know people like like you know
blondel or bergstone that there's more
there and
and there's you know a lot better stuff
than i've come across
uh in in thinking about him but i i
don't see him as as somebody who you
absolutely
have to engage with um like i said i i
like some of his ideas about
the will as being absolutely
fundamental and foundational i i don't
tend to think that things are as
unfigurable
or unrepresentable or as
holy ultimately irrational as he makes
them out to be
and i don't buy into his you know sort
of
opposite of of leibniz's optimism his
his
form of pessimism um but he's somebody
well worth worth reading
so this is this is not getting anything
anything
deep or profound on this question
because i don't actually have anything
deep or profound to offer
so we have another question by jf assa
about
sort of methods in in doing philosophy
or the practice of philosophy
um i've tried many times to read
philosophical works but i find them very
hard is there something wrong
in in my way um
so not knowing actually what what you've
been doing i
there's there's only so much i can say
specifically about
about this but i will say this
philosophical works by their very nature
are hard and even after reading them
multiple times
often do remain hard and it can be
sometimes because of the
terminology that's being used and
sort of assumed as uh you know everybody
reading this will automatically know it
kant is very bad for that sort of thing
because oftentimes people are writing to
a educated public and a particular
educated public that already knows
the the the sense of terms like a priori
and a posteriori
and you know the difference between
analytic and synthetic and things like
that
so that can be an issue and you know
well you can sometimes get around that
by by looking through glossaries or
philosophical
encyclopedias by the way encyclopedias
are better than dictionaries for
philosophy because at least with
encyclopedias you get some context
dictionaries you just get
one person's take which could be correct
or incorrect about what the term
means and oftentimes terms will mean
something in one person's philosophy and
not quite the same thing in another's
so you know it could be the terminology
the concepts themselves in philosophy
because
you know when it's done well sort of a
systematic study
of of reality whether the reality
of you know being as such the reality of
political structures the reality of the
good life
the reality of the nature of the human
person these are these are hard things
to get at so
you know don't feel bad about
it being difficult for you
so this is a question by the fates have
warned
what do i think about certain monistic
theories of mind
and it doesn't actually say what the
certain ones of those are
so i'm going to think about this in more
general terms
i tend to be very suspicious of any sort
of monism that means an attempt to
reduce
everything down to one basic principle
or to say everything is made up of
one fundamental type of stuff whether
it's materialism
whether it's idealism i tend to be
suspicious of that and i tend to be
attracted to philosophers like for
example maurice blondell
who are themselves also very suspicious
of this kind of thing um
so you know whether it if it's monistic
theories in general
i tend to be um not not very big on them
you know i study people who who are
monists
but i generally don't find myself
attracted to them
and so you might say well then you must
be a dualist right well i think
i think that you know the opposition
between those is a little bit too
simplistic
and what we want to do before beginning
from assumptions that
everything is this or everything is this
or everything is explained through this
very reductionist ways of doing things
we actually want to be good you know
essentially phenomenologists and see
what's out there
and then we try to see you know those
good dialecticians
you know what have other people had to
say about these things and what in what
they have to say
seems to be worth thinking about or
perhaps even you know
taking on as part of our ideas and then
we want to be systematic
and critical in how we put this stuff
together and i think when we do that
then then monisms of various sorts tend
to become less and less attractive
this is really the second half of the
question that the fates of warren was
asking me about about monism and
specifically about theories of mind
and when we talk about theories of mind
we mean theories of mind and everything
else
if it's a monistic theory it's saying
that mind is reducible
to other things or that everything is
mind because
if it's a monistic theory you gotta have
one thing
and everything's got to be instances
or modes or developments or epiphenomena
of that
that particular thing that maybe
substance
right so he asks which monistic theory
do you think is the most defensible and
which one do you think
is the least um
and if we're talking about defensible
you know can you provide some sort of an
account of it
well they're all kind of on the same
lines there
and it depends on what you what you're
willing to accept
or what you want to accept because a lot
of times
these things are driven by desire rather
than pure rationality
uh into your your ontology so
um i'm not i'm not somebody who's
particularly keen on
monistic explanations of things or in
thinking like a monist i suppose you
know among the people who you could say
were monists the ones who i like the
most
would be the stoics you know because the
stoics were materialists and i i really
enjoy their
their philosophy and then uh hegel who's
an idealist
i'm not big on on most
reductionist materialist ways of looking
at things i'm not big on
on spinoza and his attempt to you know
make everything
one substance and then everything else
just modes of that substance
what i do like about hegel is that
there's a there's an attempt at least to
get
everything in there and not say this
isn't really real this isn't really real
this isn't really real this isn't really
real
but then you know it's precisely that
that
um bringing everything together in one
big thing that i
tend to reject in hegel i like the
dialectical development but not
where it ends up
so this is a very important question in
the philosophy of human nature
and it's asked by emmy star uh what do
you think about the self
are we rational animals what is the
difference between
human beings and animals and
i guess you know you usually
traditionally what we've done
is we've said human being is within
the kingdom of animals but we are
rational beings
so that's our thing that sets us apart
and then you can say well what is what
is it to be rational what is rationality
itself
and i think that for me
uh and this is going to be very you know
sketchy here because i'm
talking about it very quickly when we
also look at the other what we call
propria the
things that are specific to human beings
um
you know like like laughter like
religion like um the forms of social
organization that we have the the
almost infinite plasticity of our
our nature and comparison other animals
i want to say that those must somehow
reflect what rationality consists in so
rationality cannot just be logic
or things along those lines and that
wouldn't fit in very well with you know
how aristotle views
logos or a reason you know it's not just
reason but also speech and it has to do
with our
recognition of values and how we respond
to them
i would also say this i think that
oftentimes you can find a
continuum where animals are doing
particularly what we call the higher
animals are doing
some of the things that human beings do
but not doing them quite at the same
level and i think that not being at the
same level is something very important
you know oftentimes people want to say
well there's got to be a very strict
dividing line here and here
and i think that maybe it's not quite
quite so cut and dry as that
this is another interesting question
that gets posed in terms of the
philosophy of religion
uh and also in some other areas as well
i suppose you could say it's an
epistemological question with some very
practical
applications and it's from version 191
do you think use of psychedelic drugs
like mushrooms or lsd
is a legitimate way to gain religious or
personal
insight and i have to say yes and no
mostly no um i
myself i tend to to view these things as
you know the the workings of uh
i see this in a materialistic way you
know drugs
alter your brain chemistry they they
allow you to
maybe see things that otherwise you
wouldn't you wouldn't be paying
attention to they'll produce
hallucinations
which may have meaning or relevance but
but you're getting out of
the experience what you're actually
bringing into
and projecting on to it so i tend to
think that these things mean a lot more
within cultural contexts rather than
just being you know the consumeristic
thing for
you know uh bored kids who
who want to you know drop some acid and
and you know see some some interesting
colors i think that
they can be very meaningful within uh
strong cultural contexts yeah
but i don't think that anything is going
on there that exceeds the realm of the
the purely material so
i would say you you get out of it what
you put into it if perhaps
you know you were ready to have some
sort of insight
but some things were holding you back
and
uh the use of these and we don't
necessarily just have to think about um
psychedelic drugs you could think about
ones that open people up to be more
empathetic like
like ecstasy does maybe that could
allow a person to do some things but i
think you know it's a dangerous way to
go
and probably not productive in most
cases and certainly not something i
would
be a big advocate of
so this is a very interesting question i
would say
in both the philosophy of religion and
also something important for the history
of philosophy insofar as
revealed religion has played a dynamic
role
in the development of philosophical
systems
and movements and viewpoints from
chandler simmons he says what are the
philosophical reasons for thinking that
god would reveal himself
through written word to his created
creature so that's getting pretty
specific and i'm going to talk about it
in a bit more
general form um what are philosophical
reasons
it's going to depend on what you count
as philosophy but i think that something
that's particularly important to
philosophy
is that philosophy becomes aware
in its practice of its own limitations
and it's got this kind of universalistic
almost totalizing way of saying i want
to take in
everything i want to understand
everything and when philosophy becomes
adequately self-critical it realizes it
might not actually have
all the tools required to do that
and this is one explanation of what
happened you know when judaism
christianity islam
intersect with philosophy that um
philosophy becomes aware in a very acute
way of its own insufficiencies its need
for being informed by something
uh outside of itself but not totally
foreign to itself
you know in some respects a greater
rationality a super irrationality that
that
to appears many to be uh irrationality
and so that that's one you know
line of reasoning that would fill that
out and you you can see that in
you know the early christian fathers who
are approaching philosophy you can see
that also in hegel in his discussion of
revealed religion you can see this in a
lot of people
i think that's one way of going at this
there's others as well but
that's a particularly compelling one for
me